all right great Grego where'd you grow
up where you're from originally uh South
Central Los Angeles Wow Hoover Street
Vermont in that area
I didn't seventies and tell me about
your childhood get both your parents
when you were kid uh no I just had my
really I had mine my mother and my
grandmother but mostly my mother because
her mother she did was door do a lot of
time in jail and all that stuff because
she's stealing all that you know what
they called boosting yeah back in the
days back she is a booster so amazing
basically just my gramma and how it
where's that where's your dad ah really
I couldn't tell you I don't know he was
like but last I heard he wasn't wearing
Texas but he wasn't around then and last
I seen my dad is probably got my six
birthday I'll sit here birthday it's
probably last time I seen him and I'd
seen him or so and so how was your
childhood it was it's kind of rough it
was rough because he basically cuz I
grew up in a house with more women than
anything more women around he wasn't
named witty male figures no brothers no
brothers see but he he was in will his
guests come this is part is kind of
funny cuz I have a different father than
my other three brothers now one of my
three brothers grew up with me the other
two was staying like with a father like
him in Compton somewhere right so I've
never even knew them I never even ever
came around anything and then the
brother that lived with us he did most
his time in camp yaa and stuff like that
so I was basically by myself
really you know without supporting like
brothers and stuff I'll have no sisters
you know you know yeah it was it was
kind of it was kind of rough growing up
and then that's why the influence from
the guys that neighborhood came in from
you know not having know that many males
around so the influence that I got from
male figures came from the streets you
know and guys in the streets that was
born
that names popped in you know and stuff
like that you know but see you joined
the gang oh yeah
which gang Hoover Hoover yeah yeah I was
moving and you know and it made me feel
like a part of something you know I was
I was a part of something there and uh I
was like you see I'm a smart guy so I
was always small you know so a lot of
guys used to test me a lot you know
cuz I was smaller so I had to pretty
much prove myself and once I got became
a member of a gang you know I really
didn't have that problems that much only
part time I had that problem was was
from guys inside the game that's from my
gang but other Outsiders never had that
problem no more that really because they
didn't want to mess around no problems
who was a powerful guy yeah especially
back then in the 80s it was they was bad
it was bad where they call him [ __ ] and
blood killers well back then it was
Crips it wasn't that this that the new
Crips and bloods things came later on
and like in the 90s and stuff but I'll
be 52 in July so I was just a crispy
without Crips you know so it wasn't he
wasn't no orange color and all this and
that it was just blue where's Crips so
you at some point got into selling drugs
right yes and that's from the time that
crack epidemic like first kicked in like
in around 83 84 83 and uh you know we
used to be me and a couple of more of my
buddies we used to hang on 81st between
Hoover month which was we'd see they
just call it the tracks right and that's
where all the drug action was going on
with guys used to come people he's come
buy drugs and stuff and it was just one
apartment building we used to hang at
where most of the UH
customers came so it was me and about
three or four of my other
homeys right and we at that time when
the first came like crack first kid
it wasn't really like if you didn't use
the pipe it was it was cool you just put
some on some weed and smoke it which we
used to do so
pretty much yeah pretty much you know so
we survived we survived the customers we
robbed some customers and then we'll go
buy us some crush it all down and make
some pre models and smoke and go rob
customers and rock you know he's go back
your back like that right never really
was trying to hurt nobody but we was
just just we like to Primos and that's
and this was our neighborhood and you
coming over here you know and uh a
couple of guys is guys in this building
this apartment building used to sell
dope for somebody and we didn't know we
heard a new that name we didn't know to
dude right which was freeway was was was
rigged someone Rick Walker's was in
there so uh they got tired of robbing
new customers and all that so they went
and told Rick so one night we was all
out there and uh this guy pulled up
jumped out of his truck hey man let me
holler at y'all man we looking at like
who the [ __ ] is this dude I mean can I
customer all right who the [ __ ] does
this do you know and he come over like
man yeah I don't got to do that didn't
look and he go he said stay here and
I'll be right back so we stayed and
somebody's like man that was great yes
Rick that was great right so he comes
back he comes back with a like a ziplock
baggie full coat so he just started
passing it to us that's just like four
or five of us and he pass it all out to
us you know just looking to sell that
silliest and come back to me and I'll
get you all some more and y'all don't
have to do all that man got to do which
I want to do and that's like where it
started like right there so we did it
some of us continue to keep smoking
promote some of us seeing the
opportunity of having this stuff and
getting to some guy making a
money you know so you know we we sold
some some of us went around there got
more he gave us more and just now look
out for us and sometimes you have money
like man a lot of money gambling or I
did this I did that you know we just go
around and he would just give a [ __ ]
right here
damn you know go go take care of
yourself man and that's how I like all
started and we went half like like four
of us went half on a car okay we all
while I got 66 yearly and we all put our
money in I think we paid probably like
six hundred six or seven hundred for it
there's a 66 year be right and we should
take turns driving but we wouldn't go
outside the neighborhood basically we
just ride between Florence and
Manchester and Vermeil and Figueroa
that's the only area we would ride
around in right but um but we meet od
packed car packed with guns and all this
and that and we just looking for stuff
like that but for us the UH the the
drugs the drug the drug game and it was
getting really popular right there and
at that time right now in that apartment
building I was sitting about it was this
uh Jamaican lived in there was Jamaican
guy he's just smoked they still call him
King flea because a Jamaican named King
flea and he used to used to cook though
he's a Kudo and he told me I just always
watch him all the time and so he
basically taught me how to cook dope and
I was on your life
14:50 which is making rock yeah yeah
turning the powder into rock right so I
just watch him and I I learned how to do
it and at that time it wasn't that many
people who knew how but I learned how to
do it real fast
so now far as Hoover is concerned you
got this different sections the 50s the
70s and 80s like that
I'm from the 70s but a lot of guys
hanging Dave's from a train I was upset
before
so a lot of guys didn't know how to cook
like I say
and I learned how to cook from Rick I
mean I freak from King flea
right so like I started coming and
getting me to cook dope they cook they
cook the dope up right
so I cook it up for him and all that
stuff and it was crazy because I don't
know how it got back to Rick but one day
I was cooking for my humming bug and he
came in the house and he game bug
laughing came back with him and showed
him like look right and I was cooking
all I was cooking the dumb I use in my
grandmother's house her dish drainer he
filled up with later like the baby food
bottles and I have him hard lined up
inside of there so he came one day and
he's seen what I was doing he seen that
I kind of knew what I was doing and he's
asked me how do you learn how to do this
in this man I was totally mushy and he
was like well I got some stuff I need
you you need you to help me out
so and one day he came and got me man I
mean I I thought he was cooking dope for
like seemed like two days all day all
day just cooking cooking cooking it
smoking Primo's and he didn't really
care I smoked that's why I stay up I
still say well for weeks weeks not just
constantly but I might stay up for a
couple of days and sleep for a few hours
and back up you know and I was young I
guess I had a lot of energy or whatever
it no really yeah and then uh he said
give us give us give us shows and it was
all kind of like car shows rap concerts
and all this different type of stuff it
needs to really look out for our
neighborhood that's why a lot of people
say Ricky dealt with over is more than
anything he has a lot of spots in our
hood you know and we used to look out
for him he looked out for us you know
and he started you know like that but
yeah but I guess they had a click on our
freeways freeway boys so I guess I was
one of them
you know it was it wasn't it was a lot
of guys think freeway boys so we really
didn't have a lot to worry about but the
only thing with me I would still caught
up between the money
make the money in gaming and I was like
straddle I was straddling the fence a
lot I struggle to friends you know
sometime I go hang out with the freeway
boys we were hanging out with with that
courage then sometime I'll be with my
homies see you're all I'm all over st.
freeway boys
some of them is because it was just the
ones that was more into the money than
the gang banging me I was straddled I
mean I didn't know which side I want to
going cuz my homies say they brought me
out of this I could say they like save
me from you I don't know you like when
when when I didn't have nobody anything
like that they call began we were still
broke I was broke and then that's when
freeway come through and now he saved me
from being broke and I had money I was
young 14 15 16 I had two cars
it was buckets no but he'll [ __ ] with it
be 16 with two course that was not I had
no license nothing right and you had a
little money put up you'll saved up for
my aging back then it was I was doing
pretty good you know where to go from
there to the escalator cuz cuz it yeah
because he was making a lot of money he
was making a lot of money and we was
making money too but see back then
and then we didn't I didn't know about
save safe I didn't know nothing about
savings like get it spinning get it
spinning so I had a bunch of stuff I had
a bunch of stuff but see I didn't have a
lot a lot of money a lot a lot of money
you know um a thousand a few thousand
and then what's my grandmother who wants
my grandmother figure well what's he got
win what was going on and everything
like that and uh and then on she see it
started cuz I wasn't going to school I
stopped going to school first I used to
these go to school and then I just
stopped one squad go straight to the
spot or whatever point great was around
16 16 I just peed my stop going to
school
you know so she said okay well if you're
gonna do this do it right you did she
started telling me how to manage my
money what I should do with the money
you know because at that point I guess
he just came came to terms that she
couldn't do nothing about it you know
she couldn't stop me so I would um she
would manage someone money put some more
money up for me and stuff you know even
when I was short she was lonely she
would loan me money she would give me
money to like I'm short like five
hundred to keep rule if she would give
it to me she would give it to me you
know just giving my money back and stuff
like that
so were you dealing as well yeah yeah we
we had to take shifts working in the
spot right he had a spot on 79th on 79th
between over a month which was the main
new main spot so we take shifts like my
mind was in the morning that's the
reason I stopped going to school because
my shift ended up being in the morning
so I couldn't go to school I had to work
the spot so yeah we was dealing in the
spice how much money were people making
back there a lot a lot because for one
that you didn't get is much the dog
wasn't the dog wasn't he like it is now
like now the dope is really garbage it's
all garbage but I can it you didn't get
as much you spent $25.00 he probably get
for what they give up for $5 now that's
probably what you were got for $25 back
then you know and that it wasn't no
fight out of rocks and nickels and dimes
all that type of stuff it was 25 50 you
know and stuff like that quarter pieces
half ounces and stuff like but it was
more pure it was more pure the dough was
better and and and it was it was it was
the dough and so right now they give you
a you might get up your gram for $5 out
here because it's garbage it's nothing
and they not make no money like that
you're not making no money these people
they make it money they have you need
like they say if you didn't get rich in
the 80s off of selling drugs you're not
gonna do it
I'm not gonna do it now that was the
time to really get rich oh yeah like I
said I can be I tell people I said I
should be rich right now I supposed to
be a millionaire right now because I was
there at the beginning you were their
hitter yeah in the Jemez because they
had all that back then they had all
these different cliques they had okay
they had freeway boys and Whitey's
Enterprise yeah third world Jesus
although drug clicks and in LA but
freeway Rick was kind of running no he
was the man he was the main we what kind
of money do you think he was making then
I didn't know he was making as much
money as he was making but not now I
know for a fact he was making millions
he was making millions he had he had he
had companies and stuff back then when a
lot of guys tested that's uh like
selling selling didn't have businesses
they just gets to have matches money
sticking money under the mattress stuff
but this man had Owen was owning he was
smart man that dude was smart he was
even he was a smart one of the party
smartest people I ever met
right and because he he took his money
and bought businesses he bought stuff he
bought stuff that would make more money
like legally you know and he was just he
was just funding it it's like it was
being funded at the beginning with the
drug money then after that it's take
care of itself and then where did he go
from there uh did yell it was easy today
alright now he's he's out he's he's uh
he's doing some stuff he's doing like
got record company and stuff like that
you know
yeah how do I talk to him in a long time
since yeah I first got out but he's uh
he has like record companies and little
rap come little rap stuff cuz that's
what's making money right now you know
so he's trying to get into that he got a
couple of artists and all that stuff
but back then right there and if you see
him if you would see him right you would
never you it never it was like my cousin
walk up and they'd be like that's Rick
he'd be like that kami with hey like
this God he wasn't he wasn't flashy he
might have our tank top and some jeans
and driving his tow truck cuz he he had
a tow truck company too
it would be driving one of his trucks
and uh that's it that's him
because back then you see a lot of guys
had to flash you guys later huh yeah you
have pants but you had to flashy guys
like I'll talk about the drugs instead
you can tell there was drug dealers cuz
they had change with the big ol my da
he's only the big turkeys ropes and he
wasn't like that he was like ignore he
would seems like you he would look he
would dress normal like like a regular
guy you would never know you would never
know and think he had all that money or
he was a guy who was smart to stay he
was smart you know he'd kept low profile
he wouldn't draw a lot of attention to
itself and um we saw one I should wonder
but we never would question it I'll
question him or even question each other
but maybe a couple of their top line cuz
he that man had so you were cooking it
where do you think it was coming from I
had no idea about being arrested tower
really experiencing
long as I was getting wet with what I
what I needed
you know owns he was he was taken care
so he put that up there to blah you're
not even questioning you know certain
things that be put in your faces just
who just blind you from the questions
you should be asking like man what the
[ __ ] is this dude getting his [ __ ] from
he either like us what the [ __ ] you
working with you know I mean but later
on when he got when he got arrested and
all that stuff being we found out where
a lot of it was which was where was from
the CIA yeah the CIA and
stuff like that they was they was he was
working for them that was giving him
stuff and uh he was working for them and
like the last time here I got caught and
I was uh that was a that he was pretty
much forced to do that the last the last
transaction he did it was pretty much
forced to do it because he s when you
get caught up with them like the Mafia
so [ __ ] you can't get out if they tell
you cuz they got all these you got all
these things on you and can snatch you
anytime he wanted to but he did his job
for him so they just let him be cool
letting going about his business and
going and finish doing what you doing
but I guess there's somebody that they
wanted there's somebody else that they
wanted but they had to use him to do it
that one last time and he end up just me
end up getting caught that one last time
banana died everything came to the light
that's why he ended up getting out you
know I'm saying yeah he was it was
dealing with some people in in uh he
said they told him we need to do this
one last one last by which was what I
think was something like 200 keys or
some [ __ ] like that you know he didn't
want to do it but here they made him do
it like you know you gonna do it you do
it or you gonna do you yeah right so I
guess he did it in and they got caught
he got caught up you know if you miss
those days
yeah I do I do I do if it's his way
better if I'm missing for the simple
fact I know what I would do now I would
do things way different way I would do
more things more like him the way he was
doing it not working for the CIA I
wouldn't want to do things like that
because what she is that once you get a
nice once you get to that level it's
it's it's dangerous but the money was
flowing and that made everything kind of
the money was flowing in and you could
uh you can you can you could make a lot
you could make a lot of money back then
a lot of money and a lot of like I said
I should be rich I should be a
millionaire right now 51 and I was
started when I was like 14 I would be
rich and then the person that did the
connection that I had I see a lot of
guys so this word turned around a lot of
the guys that died that was a couple of
my homies that was with me you know the
one in my little crew some of those some
of them just went totally like stop
doing drugs and they started really
making a lot of money you know me some
of us kept doing drugs like a couple
hours he was still sneaking closeted
smoking and stuff like that you know and
it ended up taking its toll on us and we
ended hug see why I ended up down hey
you know you're living on Skid Row you
never not skiing bro you know what is it
about crack or or other drugs that just
undermines a person's ability to thrive
and be successful in life and all if it
seems to because it's it's like I know a
lot of other drugs I got kid cuz there's
the drug dad that beat me up the most
was crack yeah what me the most PC I did
PCP but not on that level you know I
just smoked a little in the end cuz I
don't really like the taste up and all
that but but crack it's it's the it's
the the high makes you feel like you're
on top of the world like they say like
you can accomplish anything but when
you're feeling like that and then it
goes like like that really fast
and you don't want that feeling and that
feeling to go away cuz now cuz now I
can't discombobulated a little bit I
want my thoughts not straight like there
was one I was hard so I gotta get it
back up there so you do it more you're
doing more and that's what it was it
takes you up brings you down real fast
to where you have to run
fry you have to do more and more to try
to stay up to that level to what your
thinking is like enacted at the time
your your your stuff is just going going
money's just going because you're trying
to keep your mind at this level drug
becomes the first priority yes more than
your family more than your job more than
your health more than yeah yep because
you really know you don't you know you
you think about the stuff but you I
don't know it's like it fools you
they're thinking like different thinking
so I swear I should sit up and get high
and swear up and down I figured out how
to get into the bank I don't know how to
get in this bank and do stuff and that's
the type of stuff it makes you think
like making think you're really smart
like you really everything you thinking
like he's super smart and what you're
not you're not you're really pretty
stupid you know select this little every
my grandmother told me once I started
getting really bad on the drugs she said
I always thought she was stronger than
that how can you let this little rock
like what you were hundred-and-some
bounces thinking pretty way that high
you letting this control you like that
she got to be stupid and it doesn't
think it was funny she said I kind of
the brokers people have the riches to
riches happy I can oh pushes so broke
have such a rich habit you know and I
never really thought about that like
that like cuz I started I was is like
the exclusive like the Richmond Road
yeah but she is the it was different
than like powder like snorting in and
stuff you after down at their time
that's gonna take his toll on you too
but not as fast as smoking rocks do
smoking rocks it goes pretty fast he
goes pretty fast any and what I think
was slow cuz I asked slowed down from
from smoking Primo's be strolling we
started smoking Primo's so it was like
like a balance there you had the
marijuana you had a cocaine
the marijuana but here it was a balance
it wasn't just one way to cocaine you're
right the marijuana keep you leveled a
little bit and it was about it
and now I ended smoking a pipe is one
day I ran out of weed so and how I used
to Kiwi like in the kitchen in the junk
drawer I have like roaches and stuff
like from little roaches a week right
so I'm looking I'm looking for some weed
and I see my mom's crack pipe
my mom had quite by the way you know
this is one at a time she was out of
jail and she was you had a guy that
apartment and all that again you know so
I was back with her not my grandmother
but things she stayed here either
upstairs for my grandmother stayed
downstairs and she stayed upstairs so I
was a voice--a Casey self-destructed I
could just go back to my grandma right
so one day I was looking for the weed
and I seen her crack pipe you know like
damn I had never seen her use it though
let me ask you a question there's a
white boy from Chicago back then this is
the 80s you're talking about how many in
in in in the south central how many
people's moms had a crack pipe in the
drawer
just about yeah like me moving CLO I say
I say hello the five or five guys that
my crew are the four are my crew out of
four or five hours Sal five hours
say maybe three three of us maybe four
of our mom smoked cocaine what's doing
it it was all over the neighborhood
it was all over right and it was really
bad on women too
they got used and abused and and
proposition then you know different type
of stuff and then I stink about my mom's
doing [ __ ] like no no but I ended up you
using her stuff using trying it because
I'd seen people doing it you know I
never did it but I used to see like the
customers cousin in the spot we had a
room say like this is spot reality but I
here didn't go in that back room back
there smoke right we let them go back to
their smokes a lot seen how they do it
so I got it I said I got no if we
couldn't find the weed so let me try it
so I put a little piece on there on the
thing and um I was history it was there
that was it it was this after that cuz
that little which I was where I was put
in the primo I had to put a quarter of
that on the pipe and to get that feeling
and it was just like straight rush like
whoa like it was like oh man I just I
just found my new high alright y'all
keep spitting on everybody I'm gonna
just do this but it was bad it was bad
it was that was the worst thing I could
ever do it you know cuz it went from
there to like I didn't even want no
smoke no Primo's no more I just wanted
to pipe until I went got me a piping I'm
creeping in the end I don't heal from
there down here from there you know
again a lot of guys was [ __ ] a lot of
people found out that I was I was really
I was messing with it
Rick found out I was messing with it
like that and he I cut me loose pretty
much pretty much cut me loose like you
know I still can go but it wasn't like
he mess with just stuff man you know you
don't want you're gonna have the money
you know so so I just like went all in
and then I'm back I'm back on the Block
robbing people
I'm back why started and I'm now I'm
back there again
but [ __ ] [ __ ] the footlight it was worse
than cuz some years that went by and you
see that got a little bit more serious
then so it's are using today no I do but
I pretty much it was like right now I
used crystal meth crystal meth beginning
crystal meth is with with what stopped
me from smoking it oh yeah
it stopped Christmas stopped me from
smoking crack cocaine so it's weird and
with the crystal meth I can like it's
something it's not this is different
from Greg I tell everybody now that
smoke crack you can say you need to
start smoking was messing with crystal
but the only thing with that it's it's
worse on your body it's worst on your
body cuz the chemicals the chemicals and
stuff is really really bad for your body
makes your bones weak and in all
different type of situations and if I
guess if the chemical attendant stuff
don't go with the chemicals in your body
it does different things to different
people but they because it started
definitely stop before smoking cocaine
cuz you don't have have you heard it
beforehand you oh yeah many people
stopped crack by using Chris using Chris
so any which is better because you keep
money you keep some money in your pocket
what car you know you're going to sleep
when you have nothing you want to sleep
when you have nothing they'd you stay
for two and a half days yeah then you
sleep for two and a half days and you
eat up everything when you wake up you'd
be so starving and hungry you want to
eat everything and this is just it's
just bad you know but it right today now
it's like right now I'm just I'm just
trying to figure out what I'm gonna do
like give kids I have a daughter have a
daughter
she's in Minnesota where mom you know
you know I haven't talked to her since
Shh
oh are you like 20 years she's like 32
right now you know and and that was
because of the drugs that was because it
drugs you you you you put everything
else on the backburner for the drug
there's so many casualties right it's
not just your job and your no your
family it's it's it's everything stuff
you know it's like it's like um like I
can say right now I can I'm hungry I'm
starving
right again a person say you give me
five bucks to go get something to eat so
like you've got five bucks in my hand
all of a sudden I'm not that hungry no
more you know I'm not that hungry no
more maybe I just go buy me a 50-cent
honeyBun
getting that 450 I go buy me a head
that's how that's how it works and then
he gets to the point - oh it's mental
it's mental cuz I didn't know times work
I was on my way I was on my way to UM go
get some dope or once I got the Doughboy
know i was finna get some dope I'll
obviously like I used the bathroom
I got you know and and that's physical
that's like mental it really goes from
the mental to the physical like I got it
knocked out [ __ ] I gotta use bathroom
real bad and I ain't even had his head
to dope yet just knowing I'm about to
get it isn't anything you're the same
I'm saying it's crazy
that's that's that's that's a that's a
drug that I suggest nobody ever well
they're all occurs right whether it's
heroin or fentanyl or cracker thank [ __ ]
nah I never did heroin I tried to snort
it I tried to snort it one time and I
didn't get it and a lot of people
telling you lucky you didn't cuz you put
it like today
and you ain't no telling where you'll be
right now and I never tried it again and
they were trying to give us for the
simple fact brother that's down here
right now
that's a heroin addict and that's one of
my brothers that I didn't know I didn't
meet him until my other brother that I
grew up with got killed he got killed
and they found him in an alley right
behind our building in an alley behind
while my apartment building was that
right up the Hali they found him and
that's when I met my other two brothers
that was in Compton and when he got
disease no now just me which is the
youngest and the oldest are still living
the torn between our deceased hmm you
know I'm good oh this he's down here
right now he's down he's heroin addict I
have a unti that died from heroin
complications from years of using heroin
and I have an uncle they died from he OD
did too much at one time
just died right there like that I'm here
and still a big factor in south-central
right yeah I know all these drugs all of
them yeah definitely that's how they
keep Italian says that that's how you
keep us controlled and keep people
control like population controls or
something like that we got to control
these people right here and that's what
I figure I don't see that's how I see it
you know because you know the ones that
put it here in the in the first place
because I don't know where final wreak
didn't mean had no boats he wasn't going
over there to Peru Colombia getting that
[ __ ] and bringing it back yourself
that stuff was given to him you know it
was given to him
and he's just it was the right man to
give it - I gotta say cuz he was smart
he was so low-key he's so low-key man
you wouldn't even know it
he was so low-key but back then it's the
eighties especially coming from Sam's
okay you got these bunch of guys that
never really had nothing you know and uh
you give them some money all they want
Holly one that's nice stuff they want
gold and stuff that just look you know
look like they have something which
which which was what they wanted they
didn't want him to take that money
anyone has to get that money and buy
property in by land and buy stuff that
can you know we could really use in the
future they wanna see gets me [ __ ] that
once you buy it it turns in the value of
it turns there's nothing you know cars
and lowriders and different stuff like
that which in a way which in a way Rick
Rick was doing the same thing with us
cuz he would pacify us with little stuff
like that you will buy his cars and
lowriders issued you know singing
different stuff like that and guns and
[ __ ] because like I said we were still
gang bang and we was making money but we
were still gang banging so we had all
top-notch weapons and stuff after awhile
like that in which um there's some like
ooze ease and all that stuff first time
came around we had vine is easing and
different stuff so the teenagers neither
was he's right mm-hmm
could you shoot him mm-hmm there's go
like that evening shot everybody but
stupid stuff it was stupid
alright great well thank you so much for
sharing your interesting story yeah yeah
you know level thing good luck with uh
where you go from here man yeah thanks I
hope you get clean yeah I'm uh no I just
want a job
no I just want to work have you ever had
a real job
yeah once once I had a job this one I
would turn 18 I worked at Burger King
don't like your bikini on Manchester are
there and I worked there for about six
months and I got fired look at your
resume home my home my home way my own
place start found that I worked it there
they start coming here that's like
hooking a bug if your resume was honest
yeah okay alright thank you so much all
right
you